my advice my counsel is that people
learn some moral psychology we're
discovering a lot these days learn about
the basic software of your mind of your
social brain and if you do that you
should develop some moral humility
you'll realize that despite our constant
feeling that we are right and there's
pure evil out there and there are stupid
people and ignorant people and enemies
who are making things terrible you'll
discover the truth is a lot more
complicated and once you do that I think
you'll be at least more open to talking
to people on the other side and that's
the crucial first step expose yourself
to people not just to ideas the other
side but actually to people we have an
enormous capacity to like people and we
meet them face-to-face once we like
people we can take their idea seriously
to extent that we only hear about people
through their ideas it's just too easy
to hate into dismiss them